Це вугілля антрацитової групи видобувається в окупованому Донбасі.
Саме звідси його раніше постачали
на українські ТЕС. Щоб позбутися
антрацитової залежності від окупованих територій,
Нацкомісія з регулювання енергетики та комунальних послуг,
запровадила півтори роки тому формулу
"Роттердам+".
Формується вона наступним чином:
беруть вартість вугілля за тонну в порту Роттердама -
це приблизно 45 доларів - та додають витрати на доставку
до України та перевантаження -
це ще 15 доларів. Загалом 60.
Однак з двадццяти п'яти мільйонів тонн вугілля,
потрібного для українських ТЕС,
торік було імпортовано лише менше п'яти відсотків.
І то понад половину - з Росії, решта -
з Південно-Африканської Республіки. Із самого Роттердама
до України не було доставлено жодної тонни вугілля,
стверджують експерти.
Але при цьому тариф на абсолютно все вугілля
в Україні чомусь вираховувався саме
за завищеною "роттердамською" ціною.
Це все одно, що продавати українцям
українську ж картоплю з прив'язкою до цін у Нью-Йорку,
тобто утричі дорожче,
порівнює колишній член Нацкомісії з регулювання
енергетики та комунальних послуг Андрій Герус.
Через "Роттердам+" ціна зросла від п'ятисот
-шестисот гривень за тонну вугілля, яке вибодувалося на Сході України,
до теперішніх півтори тисячі гривень.
Відповідно зросли й тарифи
на електроенергію для промисловості: з вісімдесяти копійок
за кіловат-годину до однієї гривні
вісімдесяти копійок.
За підрахунками експертів, українські споживачі на формулі "Роттердам+"
переплатили понад 10 мільярдів гривень
за тарифами.
Це, по суті, мала бути ціна за обіцяну
вугільну незалежність від антрациту із зони АТО.
Але гроші забрали, а незалежності так і нема,
нарікають експерти.
Різні журналістські розслідування дійшли висновку:
формула допомогла збагатитися насамперед таким структурам, як ДТЕК
олігарха Ріната Ахметова, та державному "Центренерго".
Тепер уперше офіційно
незаконність дії формули "Роттердам+"
підтвердило й НАБУ. Його голова Артем Ситник повідомив,
що проводиться розслідування
щодо факту зловживання службовим становищем
посадовими особами НКРЕ, які затвердили формулу.